today we're going to talk about
biodiversity so biodiversity as you
might have guessed comes from two words
biological and diversity and essentially
it's the variations or the diversity
present between living things
now i grew up in the sunny state of
arizona and at first glance there
doesn't seem to be much variety in such
a hot and dry place i mean it's the
desert right
but if we take a closer look at a place
such as the sonoran desert and here's a
picture we would find all kinds of
different living things like saguaro
cacti
jackrabbits
tarantulas
silver-haired bats and the roadrunner
which is my personal favorite
so we can say that the desert is
actually quite biodiverse so in other
words it's home to a large variety of
living things
since there are both big and small
differences between different living
things we can think of biodiversity on
three different levels so the first and
smallest scale level is going to be
genetic biodiversity which is just the
genetic variation within a group of
organisms and a really great example of
this kind of biodiversity is the rock
pocket mouse and i know that's a
mouthful of words to say but it's really
cute i mean look at this picture
so this is a species that can actually
be found right here in the sonoran
desert and the cool thing about this
mouse species is that there exist both
tan and black colored rock pocket mice
so even though both colored rodents come
from the same species their genetic
biodiversity creates mice with
completely different traits and what's
even more awesome is the fact that these
colors tan and black have come about due
to natural selection
so scientists have found that there are
more black colored rock pocket mice in
places with dark
black-ish lava rock while there are more
tan colored rock pocket mice in lighter
colored sands and this makes sense
because if you think about it the mice
are hunted from above by predators like
birds so having a coat color that blends
into their surroundings would increase
their chances of survival so having this
kind of genetic biodiversity is really
great because the rock pocket mice can
use many different colored landscapes as
habitats and if let's say the landscape
color were to change and suddenly become
dominated by dark lava rock then this
population of mice would have the
genetic diversity that it needs to adapt
to this change
so the second level is species
biodiversity which is the variety of
species in a particular area so going
back to the sonoran desert there are all
kinds of mammals and birds plants and
insects but what i think is even more
mind-boggling is the sheer number of bat
species there are i mean we have
silver-haired bats as i mentioned
earlier but also
bats like spotted bats western red bats
and even this kind of bat called peter's
ghost faced bat which i think is a
really awesome name and you're probably
thinking okay abby this is really
interesting but so what
well like genetic biodiversity species
biodiversity is super duper important
because having a lot of different
species means that more roles can be
filled in an ecosystem which makes the
ecosystem healthier
so moving on to the final level we have
ecosystem biodiversity and this is just
the variety of ecosystems on the planet
now we've been talking a lot about the
sonoran desert and a desert is actually
a type of ecosystem on earth and if you
recall ecosystems are made up of both
living things and their physical
environment so in this case living
things in the desert ecosystem could
include things like rattlesnakes
scorpions and cacti while non-living
things could include rock formations or
sand dunes and in addition to desert
ecosystems earth has forest ecosystems
coral reef ecosystems all kinds of
different ecosystems and having all
these different kinds of ecosystems is
extremely critical for our survival
because the diversity of ecosystems on
earth provide us humans with important
resources and services so without
ecosystem biodiversity our quality of
life and in fact our very survival could
be at risk
so as you can tell every level of
biodiversity is incredibly important for
unique reasons
now biodiversity doesn't remain constant
so we can think of biodiversity as
something that can change over time now
the important thing to remember is that
speciation increases biodiversity while
extinction decreases biodiversity
so let's talk about speciation first so
speciation happens when one species
evolves into two or more species over
time
and you might have heard or seen
something that looks like this and i'll
draw it out right here to the right and
this is just a very simple speciation
model or a phylogenetic
tree so we have here a common ancestor
that branches off into different species
over time
this arrow representing time or t for
short and it's speciation events like
these that have led to the biodiversity
that we see on earth today
on the flip side we have extinction
which causes biodiversity to decrease
and what we mean by this word extinction
is that a species or population of
living things dies off completely so
notice that it can happen on different
levels too for example if a population
goes extinct then we no longer have the
genetic variance in the gene pool or the
set of genes for a particular species
but if a species went extinct entirely
then that species is no longer there to
fulfill its unique role or its
ecological niche so you might have heard
of the dodo bird which is a species that
actually went extinct way back in the
1600s
so some of the major causes behind the
dodo birds extinction include over
hunting
habitat loss and competition with some
newly introduced species and
unfortunately the last dodo bird was
reportedly killed in 1681 and even
though we can't enjoy the presence of
dodo birds anymore learning about this
extinct bird actually brings up a really
good question that is what effect do
humans have on biodiversity right now
well it's sad to say but humans are
actually causing biodiversity to
decrease
things like
climate change habitat destruction and
over exploiting resources have caused a
huge loss of biodiversity and if you
remember having biodiversity is really
critical to our survival which is a big
uh-oh in fact species extinction is now
occurring at a rate 100 to one thousand
times faster than the background rate
detected in fossil records and because
the extinction rate is much bigger than
the speciation rate the result is an
overall loss or decrease in biodiversity
so today we learned about biodiversity
which is the variety of life present on
earth we talked about three different
levels of biodiversity
moving from genetic biodiversity to
species and then ecosystem biodiversity
and we also talked about how
biodiversity isn't stagnant or fixed in
place we have speciation events that can
increase biodiversity and extinctions
that decrease biodiversity
and finally we learned that human
actions are threatening biodiversity as
we currently have a greater extinction
rate than speciation rate